supongamos que por alguna razón le
prestas al gobierno mil pesos así que el
gobierno te da un documento formal en
donde te dice el gobierno te debe mil
pesos y esto es emitido por la tesorería
y es lo que conocemos como bonos o
certificados de la tesorería cetes y
supongamos que la reserva federal es
decir el banco central está interesado
en introducir dinero en nuestro sistema
entonces vamos a decir que aquí tenemos
la reserva federal y lo que ellos hacen
es crear mil pesos en bonos de la
reserva federal lo que para nosotros es
papel moneda entonces lo crean y te lo
pagan comprando así los llamados bonos
de la tesorería así que el bono de la
tesorería pasa de la reserva federal a
ti y tú obtienes los billetes nuevos que
la reserva federal acaba de emitir aquí
están tus mil pesos
ahora qué te gustaría hacer con esos mil
pesos bueno tal vez no sea seguro
caminar por la ciudad con ese dinero en
tu bolsillo por eso es que muchas
personas prefieren depositarlo en un
banco pero pensemos que es lo que pasa
con el balance del banco supongamos que
estamos en el banco
pero pensemos en qué es lo que pasa con
sus activos y sus pasivos cuando
realizas el depósito para activos y pp
para pasivos bueno si tú depositas esos
mil pesos entonces en los activos del
banco podemos decir que el banco obtiene
mil pesos en reservas en reservas pero
cuando tú les diste el dinero ahora
ellos tienen un pasivo contigo es decir
una responsabilidad contigo porque debes
de tener una cuenta de depósito activa
ahora tienes una cuenta activa de mil
pesos que para ti es como un activo pero
es un pasivo para el banco y en
cualquier momento puedes hacer uso de
esos mil pesos que tienes en tu cuenta
ahora en muchos vídeos ya hemos hablado
sobre los préstamos de reserva
fraccionaria y vimos que existen dos
formas en las que podemos conceptualizar
lo pero vamos a hacerlo de la forma más
sencilla supongamos que este banco dice
bueno nos encontramos en un mundo en
donde nuestro requisito de reserva voy a
poner el requisito de reserva aquí el
requisito de reserva en este país es del
10% lo cual significa que el banco solo
tiene que retener el 10% de estas
reservas de dinero y puede prestar lo
demás y eso es lo que hace ese es el
modelo de negocios o al menos una parte
significativa de su modelo de negocios
así que en lugar de tener mil pesos en
reservas
solamente retiene el 10% entonces se
queda con 100 pesos en reservas y presta
lo demás presta 900 pesos a alguien más
le presta 900 pesos tal vez es alguien
que va a invertir en su negocio
a una casa o algo por el estilo pero
nuevamente el banco no solo le dio el
dinero sino que obtuvo un activo que en
este caso es un pagaré o una deuda de
esa persona ahora esa persona le debe
900 pesos al banco podemos decir que a
cambio de darle a esa persona dinero
ahora el banco tiene un préstamo de 900
pesos como activo en su balance y para
la persona a la que le prestaron el
dinero el préstamo será un pasivo porque
debe ese dinero pero para el banco es un
activo alguien me debe a mí el banco 900
pesos pero qué es lo que hará esta
persona bueno el bolsillo de esta
persona estará lleno pero tampoco quiere
pasear por la ciudad con 900 pesos en su
bolsa así que seguramente lo va a
depositar en un banco puede depositarlo
en el banco o en otro banco vamos a
decir que en el banco ve y es muy
creativo el nombre verdad
entonces el banco ve hace lo mismo yo
creo que ya saben hacia dónde vamos con
todo esto aquí tenemos sus activos y sus
pasivos entonces ahora esta persona va a
depositar los 900 pesos aquí y el pasivo
correspondiente es que cuando la persona
le da el dinero a este banco esa persona
puede exigir ese dinero a este banco así
que el banco le crea una cuenta bancaria
de esa manera la persona puede hacer uso
de esa cuenta para comprar la maquinaria
que necesita para su negocio o lo que
sea que necesite pero nuevamente existe
un requisito de reserva del 10% que dice
que el banco solo debe retener el 10%
entonces como el modelo de negocios es
que solo va a conservar el 10% de esto
puede prestar lo demás así que prestará
810 pesos puede ser en un solo préstamo
o como un conjunto de varios préstamos
que sumen esa cantidad entonces supongo
que esto es prestado a alguien más que
ahora tiene 810 pesos y ahora puede
depositar los en otro banco que
posiblemente será el banco ce y que a su
vez podrá prestar el 90 por ciento de
esa cantidad y ese proceso se repetirá
una y otra vez así que una pregunta muy
interesante es que dada la inyección
inicial de dinero los mil pesos y dado
este requisito de reserva cuánto dinero
se ha creado en total en otros vídeos
hemos hablado sobre las múltiples
medidas de la oferta monetaria así que
cuando la reserva federal pone estos mil
pesos es decir pone mil pesos en
billetes de la reserva federal en
circulación incrementa por mil pesos la
base monetaria pero una medida de la
oferta monetaria nos dice bueno cuál es
el dinero que hay en circulación de la
reserva federal es decir las monedas o
el papel moneda más la cantidad de
depósitos a la vista conocidas como
cuentas de cheques
corrientes ya hablamos de eso en otros
vídeos y es conocido como el agregado
monetario m1 vamos a ver cuál sería la
medida m 1 bueno esta persona tiene una
cuenta con mil pesos mil pesos entonces
como tiene mil pesos el banco le tiene
que dar ese dinero pero esta otra
persona tiene 900 pesos en su cuenta
tiene 900 y cuando esta persona deposite
su dinero en el banco entonces tendrá
una cuenta con 810 pesos y este proceso
se repetirá una y otra vez porque cuando
estos 810 pesos estén depositados el
banco prestará el 90 por ciento de eso y
otra persona tendrá otra cuenta entonces
lo que hacemos aquí es multiplicar cada
vez por 0.9
es decir que multiplicamos por uno menos
el requisito de reserva ya hemos hecho
los cálculos muchas veces en otros
vídeos
es igual a mil la cantidad con la que
iniciamos la base monetaria por 1 entre
1 menos 0.9 y eso será igual a 1.000 por
1 entre 0.1 o simplemente podemos verlo
como uno entre el requisito de reserva
que en este ejemplo es 0.1 requisito de
reserva y así es como podemos hacer el
cálculo 1 entre un décimo es igual a 10
por lo tanto nuestra oferta monetaria m1
que se creó en este ejemplo es igual a
10 por mil así que es igual a 10.000
pesos entonces a gran escala cuando la
base monetaria se incrementa por una
cierta cantidad si conocemos el
requisito de reserva y suponemos que
todos los bancos minimizan sus reservas
para solo conservar el 10% no el 11-12 o
20%
este cálculo nos muestra cuál será el
efecto máximo en la medida m1
a esa inyección en la base monetaria
dada esta cantidad que fue infundida por
uno entre el requisito de reserva nos
vemos en otro vídeo